bene ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video siamo di nuovo con la coop con
dido infatti c'è anche di do ragazzi qui
dice onorato di essere sul canale di
parigi e io sono onoratissimo di avere
ovviamente anche dito ospite allora
eravamo animati comunque su su questa
specie di aereo e diciamo non eravamo
gli ospiti benvenuti il pil non proprio
sì forse dimenticati la nostra totale
bellezza beh siamo dei sex symbol
completo alla e tutto il resto ne frega
no vabbè comunque ragazzi
è fantastico mi gioco il primo episodio
secondo me è stato etico poi adesso non
so che cosa ci troveremo davanti più
tanto che avviso giacché più bella e più
accadendo cose assurde quindi nato
allora ci sia ma secondo dato come armi
cos'hai sono io c'è una pistola ok
allora non sono solo io che ci sono un
povero di armi sì sì sì no perché una
volta che c'è un comizio ha preso
fossero perciò 108 tutto con i rei
abbiamo armi pari ci siamo allora non si
possa prendere ami ok ma non detto
chiaro sto video perché con qualcosa di
fuori da ogni regola umane si no questo
gesto sicuro non c'è proprio la mano con
soldi lo bene perché è schifoso che
bello che bello
mamma mia ragazza e fantastica giovani
agli occhi vedere le vive di facebook no
ma sta succedendo azioni che bova beale
macchine perfette
ok e siamo ancora vivi un lieve mal di
testa momento è tutto a posto
sono una macchina in faccia di si
prendono e beccati qua in volo dove
dovere 36
io sono in volo ma mi sa che questa
parte qua la vediamo ognuno vede la
propria perché io tipo adesso sto
abbracciando amorevolmente mio amico qui
anch'io al che allora franco chieco
diario ti senti ti vedo ti vanti
io vedo male allora abbiamo tutti e due
un amico ad abbracciare cioè momenti di
affetto non mancano nemmeno so se in tre
ragazzi al gay abbracciamoci anche noi
vieni qui vieni qua barra sbalzate
spaziatrice gira verso l'alto a un caffè
esiste nostri cuochi
io non so cosa sto sparando i tiratori
tc di tipo mi andavo a imitare a me
quale regola umana potrebbe rendere
possibile il brano so ma se entro non si
è fatto sui problemi dice sono stati
appunto le macchine dobbiamo scavare si
può prendere 200 all'ora
suppongo che siamo in stiva ragazzi
meglio di felix baumgartner qua altro
che barriera del suono usato altri note
dei pesi c'è più che 360 sarà un 2.800
qualcosa di più ma che stiamo per
arrivare alla meta ragazzi madre della
ragazza un di la meta ok la pres
ma tu dove sei adesso hai preso la banca
si cielo in braccio e allora ce
l'abbiamo tutti e due perché basati su
chi guarda ora è un addio non è pacifico
vero quello io ora sto zitto e ti faccio
vedere la scienza anche se mi sto per
immaginare che non è che non ho preso
una mano in faccia prima quindi non so
quanto la salda la protesta pur esiste
però non puoi capire cosa sta per
accadere
ok ragazzi assistiamo per chi di voi lo
assiste per la prima volta diciamo che
si sta avvicinando molto amorevolmente
per un abbraccio anche il nostro amico
aeroplano spara la finestra
oddio cos'è no no non ci credo
mamma mia ragazzi mamma james bond ci fa
una bocca ma cos'era ma mi vuoi dire che
era c'è tipo in un tunnel poche parole
io cederei 9 a nome fantastico ragazzi
questo è il senso di entrare in galleria
cioè poche parole di mamma mia 10
avviare arrivato anni temi con altri
campi del fuoco perché secondo me andava
contro ogni legge della fisica c'è
newton che nella tomba si sta tirando le
craniate però preso epico lei un altro
amico producendo si ok mi sa che il memo
dietro di me che picchia un senso nemo
che sono vera venuta tutto qualche io tu
sei più avanti perfetto così avanti a
tutto ma vedi degli spari di sopra non è
il vicino ma sono io che che si è anche
preso vero va fantastico
io sto prendo tutte le scatole possibili
non devo fare così vero ok siamo di jean
di debiti di non sparare ascianghi mi
raccomando sì sì no no no perfetto l'ho
presa anche tu pensi
l'abbiamo salvato la vita lei ci
ringrazia dicendo se l'uomo della mia
vita in poche parole no è stato detto
che ce la dà è questo l'importante è
importante averlo siamo tranquilli
questo qui una pomata e passa tutto il
dotto malissimo il nostro amico beh
penso che dio c'è dai manga mi 22 lo so
se visto da gava senesi site guardalo
c'è lui beh perché tipo fighissimo
rispettato sei tranquillo
il boss 5 dollari stiamo prelevando ma
abbiamo mica miliardi guarda che bello
il primo piano in quel primo guai
il primo il primo piano davvero quella
era vendere una cosa che non dovevano ok
bello s'inquadra youtube
sì esatto quando i bancomat non riesci a
prelevare diciamo alla reazione questa
che vorremmo avere tutti quanti comunque
rispetto
siamo a questa la bara di rispetto cosa
che è che serve serve per le emissioni
cioè qui non qui non è che si basino
solo mi sembra sull'andare avanti con la
storia ma più rispetto ai più sbocchi in
emissioni cena sì sì sì sì sì ho capito
si sbloccano un tot di rispetto e per il
rispetto sì lo si acquisisce c'è facendo
casino in giro in poche parole sono
casini in giro facendo secondarie cose
così achievement ha sbloccato comitato
di benvenuto bene ragazzi benvenuti nel
mondo di centro
fermi ai lavorando vederci insieme o una
spessa quadro sta caricando un secondo
non so cosa tutta sta caricando
ok ti vedo però vai asca o perfetto
ragazzi i momenti di brividi momenti da
brivido anzi italiano è andato a morire
bene cosa fa adesso siamo liberi ragazzi
siamo finalmente liberi nel mondo di
saints row delle quote abbastanza
imbarazzanti no no no ma noi non lo so
che cosa fare adesso
io so cosa vuoi fare almeno una pizza
faceva vedere se una cosa
guardami da sei che ho perso sa che devo
farti vedere una cosa provava vai un due
tre.un ma che sexy ore 9
questa mia rapa ragazzi questa mamma mia
che di dietro da favola
così come faccio io poi fatto aspetta
aspetta e primate faccio dire ancora una
poi vai vai nostra 1200 abilitava
ragazzi no questo questo ragazzino un mi
piace solo per questi ragazzi ci vuole
tutto qua ci sta tutto e fantastico e io
non so dove farlo ovviamente ma la
tastiera
cosa ti ha fatto cosa ti ha fatto
ma perché no vabbè tanto oramai
ok tu ce l'hai col marciapiede c'è ma
vabbè ce la prendiamo con qualsiasi cosa
la puglia no vabbè entriamo in qualche
macchina a caso tipo moto cosa facciamo
tipo questo vengo io volevo io sono un
po cazzeggiando con i passanti
non so cosa come conoscendo ips i brand
o qua da sofia polizia ok perfetto e non
ha solo incavolata in verità no perché
egizia li guardi e se in carcere qui non
lasciano al più libero diciamo sì dunque
chino di più in effetti piazza dove dove
sei ma e ti perdo vedo che tutti dai
fastidio passato ar che io ho ragazzi lo
scherno io faccio il conteggio ok buona
sera stava un po faccio una cosa così
però son queste cose da cazzeggio
assoluto che indro induce a fare queste
cose bisogna farle è solido bisogno io
no cosa faccio adesso può venire legnini
due o si può andare in due fantastico tu
fai la città dietro sexy che mi viene io
vado avanti cosa cosa dobbiamo fare
non voglio vado a casa ed al triangolino
immaginava qui a ma non era bowling
assieme però su sei troppo scusate
centro bellamy a pronunce sono ovvero
briosa ok perfetto dove dovevano
sinistra destra veloce ok pausa scusa no
no avevo mollato la tastiera perché
avevi messo in pausa che è bene file
cosa dove andiamo andiamo lì bello
andiamo
sei capace di dare tutto tutto soffriva
del sonno che nella corsia giusta vai di
mi dovetti porto vai triangolo blu
triangolo blu psi perfetto ma in
versione così ok ci sembra fuori non
contano i sto gioco verano andiamo al
triangolo vai domande ma
ok perfetto tanto valutano perché non so
dove sia andato ho visto che per questo
non vale se c'è quella potente ma adesso
facciamo che ti seguo eccidio di lo
spericolato chi segue vedo sedi scorsa
pietro vai vai vai ragazzi sarà un
imperfetto sono partito male perché la
macchina di sé inseguendo vai vai tu hai
spedito io ci provo
ok depp e per ora allora salto un
secondo il triangolino venne quelli di
emozioni sotto di essi stessi cece
convinta la sfida fra i due famiglie
dove su spa vj gara di corsa ma è stato
bravo in giochi del genere però di
sicuro primo palo che becco lo bello beh
no ok perfetto grazie ragazzi perfetto
mi sono portato fortuna da solo e sono
la terra non trovo più la mia moto ti ho
perso letteralmente è l'ex hanno un po è
vero e cerca di trovare la mappa e
provami normative di ti vedo ancora in
lontananza faccio l'autostop pregando in
un passato che ai 6 centrato su
triangolino no no ci vorrà potenza falli
mail che è successo per chi abbiamo
abbandonato shaun di come una merda ma
no non può pretendere che lo accompagna
ovunque dai 16 molto al massimo è fatto
per due
esistono i taxi cena ha senso una moto
fantastica a facciamo quesito tolto
troviamo una moto guido io così faccio
un po di trick si segue aveva a bordo di
qualcosa va bene arrivo
buono ok ho sbagliato una cosa volevo
eccolo qua
ok totò ripreso in tempo che anche
questo qui che di sicuro non si stava
godendo tutto quanto avrà fantasy questo
aveva freddo
penso io tornerò a questo modo di non
condurre il sud sino a fargli passare le
giornate se la prese cose esatto perché
lo aspettiamo che siano è morto già e va
bene ci si pone anche divertire questa
qui sarebbe la tipa che è che non sa
andare non si sa trovare un taxi su
questa cosa non gli stasi non mi sta
simpatica lo dico subito però andiamo
andiamo dove dove dobbiamo andare buona
macchina macchie ok ho fatto qualcosa
che non dovevo fare
ma da devil may cry e le mutande per la
giusta passa macchina serviva forse per
andare a questa si sa si è entrato
proprio in maniera elegante devi fare
quello che la corsa per entrarci tipo
stile
maggiordomo ne aprì la porta e mi fermo
io mi godo il viaggio ragazzi perché
invito siamo in mani sicure un pilota
migliore non f
non la pensava lo stesso anche guidatore
e meglio è ma io sono morto si dice file
ad ora arriva questa questa non è
proprio io vado nel cestello sai che non
posso salita voci poi sotto per due a
meno che non ho nomi scambino per un
coniglio posso stare lì dietro no non
penso
hai anche ragione allora troviamo il
camion dell'immondizia sicuramente
meglio ma quanta violenza
ecco il mio posto siamo se non la domani
e io vado piuttosto vado in mezzo
all'immondizia però da qualche parte
devo salire
volevo una moto per fare due trick
uffa cerchiamo di fondo c'è chi le cose
non ne trovi mai per quanto ce l'hai
passano tutti di fianco penso anche io
ho perso la corsa minimi a buy
retromarcia serie c che qui non riesco a
non adesso magari che ci sono in mezzo
alla strada come adesso fantasma sa qui
mi ruba il posto sempre fatto fuori jean
di che va non posso allora facciamo mai
aspetta un attimo
vai vai surf sui veicoli ok ok ci
dovremmo riuscire ragazzi io vado tipo
improvvisata così che così di certo non
aiuti
mai così cioè che io cercherò di tenere
l'equilibrio per tutta la durata
perfetta non ce l'ha fatta
no sono a terra dietro si sono mai
schivato non sa neanche come perché ero
convinto di riprenderci meno male allora
ci riprova di nuovo ragazzi perché è
stato qualcosa di fantastico allora ci
dovrei riuscire stavolta perché ho
capito più o meno il meccanismo allora
vai così vai vai a vado vado chiedendo
anche la vita dico dio oddio ma guarda
anche in verticale vuole senza mani set
vinto da quando abbiamo affidato a sua
mamma mia ragazza ok perfetto ho preso
una moto ai 200 all'ora sulla nuca la
classico si sposta quasi posare in due
ok bonus
comunque secondo me ragazzi e
e fantastico come come gioco in cile
comunque secondo me è meglio arrivare al
punto e poi smettere perché siamo
oltrepassando il limite proprio di
registrazione ok io vado dietro
adesso che abbiamo trovato la moto ci
siamo mai regala chiuso un ultimo sogno
o son di stupida merda in crisi ne frega
lascia lì che perdiamo per colpo sugo
alla fine mamma mia ragazzi non può
neanche seguirci macista secondi
macchina si va dai allora almeno qual
cosa la sa fare non è una donna inutile
però le donne al volante non è che
perfetto ho finito di dirlo ha investito
un passante bene anche noi non è che
siamo no no cosa fai
sono finito sta finendo in mezzo alla
posta perfetto dovevo fare parti pari al
volo ma ci stava tutto dai va bè ragazzi
direi che possiamo chiudere qui perché
abbiamo siamo oltre il tempo limite
ricordate il prossimo episodio ho
trovate sui canali di dido quindi alla
ti scrive è andato a scrivervi sul suo
canale per gli scritti di famiglie tv
sono setako riscritti iscrivetevi come
al solito lasciato mi piace un commento
diventato fa sua pro peggio che qui su
youtube
beh ragazza